hello everyone welcome to another
exciting game from round 8 of the
Croatian Grantchester being played in
Zagreb it's an issue with the white
pieces I can shower mommy Europe mummy
are not having the greatest tournament
so far or the greatest year for that
matter but you know let's let's just see
how he does in this game and then we're
gonna talk about that a bit more
so without further ado let's just check
it out we do we don't have one game but
it's from the post game sorry one photo
but it's from the post game analysis
we're gonna show that later and we said
that we were gonna show one more game
from round 8 also be at also check out
the standings so without further ado
night of three by giri the rate is on
the board we have C 6 C 5 and now giri
transposes into the sicilian efore we've
Knight to c6 and now Bishop to b5 Giri
goes for the news Medina Barroso limo
attack Bishop to b6 vitamin D are of
castles by giri and now Bishop to d7
now the knight can move with c3
preparing the for by giri and Knight to
f6 now putting pressure on the e4 pawn
with rook to e1 defending the pawn but
also after the bishop is on is attacked
you will not be you will not be forced
the capture you can also just nicely
targeted the shipping away for a for
later so with a six by mommy sheriff and
now Bishop to f1 you can go to e2 as the
rock has to keep an eye on the e4 pawn
Bishop to g4 now by mommy you're off and
now you could go h3 just asked the
bishop wherever it wants to go but first
d4 by giri we've see captures c captures
and now d5 pi mama DRF asking do you
wanna advance the pawn or capture we
have captures by giri Knight captures in
mount knights the c3 continuing
development attacking the knight on d5
with ecigs preparing to develop the dark
square bishop and now h3 asking what do
you want to do with the bishop and here
capturing on f3 is the main line but mom
Yara opts for a different one with
what's up to h5 and now he says okay my
bishop is still very nice here if you
want to get rid of it you're gonna have
to weaken the the deposition in front of
your King you're gonna have to put g4
and this is exactly what give it
with g4 bishop to g6 and now if you
could somehow you know castle your king
the safety would black develop your
pieces and start an attack on the King
side then the weekend King inside will
be favorable for black but Geary doesn't
allow it the first night capture Sun d5
you cannot recapture with the pawn as
its pinned here so you have to capture
with the Queen Queen captures on d5 by
Mahmoud ER and now Bishop to g2 and this
is nothing new this has all been played
before but now already white is
threatening some well not so nasty
discoveries but there are discoveries as
there's the bishop is aligned with the
Queen and d5 so here you you either
gonna move your queen away or you just
play Bishop to e7 and get ready to
castle your king to safety as soon as
possible but here mama D are actually
plays queenside castle and it's well it
does make sense if white doesn't have a
good way of day of taking advantage of
this pin because white already has a
pretty much messed up pawn structure
another messed up but the pawns are
already advanced in front of the White
King so you can just start an attack
open up the game and you will have a
nice will maybe even winning attack
would black the problem is given does
have a very nice discovery here he plays
Knight to e5 instead of 95 there is also
a very sneaky lined Bishop to g5 just
attacking the rook and after f6 only
then Knight to e5 and after well you
have to do something with a queen after
queen capture son before now Queen to b3
but it's really just maybe too much of a
Michael Falcon kind of position to
expect anyone to go into this for
example if punk actress Angie v then you
can capture on c6 after B captures
you're gonna go rook a c1 and everything
is under attack here the e6 pawn is
under attack the c6 bone is under attack
the rook isn't such a beautiful you know
a file here are also this recovering the
e-file suggests the entire mess of a
position and the white should prevail in
this line but gear it goes for a
different one here after queenside
castle he goes for 95 a right away
attacks the Queen with Queen captures
here
and now Quinta f3 by Gary and this has
all been played before there is actually
one game that reached this position now
you don't have the option of capturing
the night because Queen captures on b7
is checkmate so you have to figure out
how to go about it
there is one game where Queen to b4 was
played and it's actually a nice move now
it now you will be able to capture as
the Queen also guards besom but you're
also threatening the rook here so first
White will have to waste a move to
develop the LightSquared Bishop but it's
not all that possible
sorry about it not all that possible to
even play this will black as the white
is already winning here but instead
mommy never played looked at d5 and this
is now a new move which is really
interesting as this is already such a
difficult position to play for black and
well it's a very often that we will
reach a new position that is or that is
equal and then something will happen but
it's very rare that we will have a
position where white is just better
and then that mom in your own AR plays a
new move in that position but ok now ok
the this diagonal is blocked so you have
to figure out what to do here but now
the f7 point is a week so gear just
captures it with Knight captures on f7
and now rook the g8 getting the rock out
of the way and now Knight to g5 and
there is no way to defend the e6 pawn
you can push it as Queen captures and e5
is coming the pond has to guard the rook
on d5 so Bishop to d6 here by momma Dee
off and now just Knight captures on e6
with an attack on the Queen here we have
Queen to b4 attacking the rook on e1 so
now you have to waste a move to develop
the bishop to connect your rooks with
Bishop to e3 and now rook the e5 getting
the rook out of the way here as the
bishop is attacking the d5 square after
the Queen moves but also now the rook
and the Queen are attacking the e1 rook
so if the bishop moves there could be
some problems for white as the bishop
also covers the h2 square after the rook
moves so it could be could be kind of
dangerous so we have a 3 by Gary pushing
the Queen back and there aren't all that
many squares the Queen can use the
bishop covers this diagonal if you move
some some like a 5 then b4 is coming so
it's
not a lot of squares mogera accepted the
challenge he plays screen capture son b2
and now just rook a to c1 and it's very
difficult to do this the problem is your
night on e6 is under attack but get
replays this wonderful attacking rook a
to see one without even bothering to try
and save the night because you cannot
save the night if you play something
like nice to f4 then you get Bishop to
b4 push the Queen back after Queen to d1
you can just trade everything but your
capture screen captures and now as your
king is on the second rank the same as
the Queen you can play rook captures on
d3 now you cannot capture with the pawn
if you capture with the rook you lose
even the night here as the Rope will not
be guarding the night so here you have
to go into Queen captures and e6 rook
captures any one rook captures anyone
and after Luke to d8
you will have this position where the
material on the board is completely
equal and the white will not be able to
do much here so Gary doesn't bother with
this Knight to f4 idea he goes straight
for the attack rook a to C one and now
you force black to capture the night
here because now you're pinned here
along this line and now Knight the d4 is
a very nice escape route as the knight
will not be able to capture on d4 so
mama d RF captures the knight with rook
captures on e6 but now feel free to
pause the video and try to find what
with Gary's idea in sacrificing this
Knight and e6 continue the attack with
white while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent sacrificer of both nights and
exchanges and for those who just wanna
enjoy the show rook captures on c6 this
is what gear we had in mind because now
if you capture it then it's just a very
nice well finishing sequence Queen
captures and c6 King v8 and now you can
play Queen to AAT check King goes to c7
now Queen a7 check King to see it you
will play Queen captures on a6 check and
now after you move the King for example
either either d7 then Queen to c6 or if
you try something like well let's say
King to forever king - king to c7
then you get
Quinta c4 check and you start picking up
material or if King b7 if you defend the
rock then again Queen to c6 like if the
king came to thee seven right away
King is seven now you get Bishop g5
check King has the MU King to f7 Queen
to d7 check and now you either go up and
then lose material as both the rook and
Bishop regarding d7 square or you're
gonna go King to f8 and then finally
Queen captures on e6 and black just
falls apart so you cannot capture the
rook otherwise you're just you know
busted
so King the d7 was played by Mahmoud er
off but now giri continues happily
trying to sacrifice the rook rook
captures on a6 and again if you capture
queen c6 we go into the exact same line
nothing really changes except well a
black accepted the rook not the first
time but the second time it's the same
Queen Easter King to e7 Bishop g5 King
here coming here and we go into the
exact same line with the points still
being an a6 but it's no different
so after rule captures on a6 we have
rook to b8 Mahmud II our brings this
rook over here to guard the b7 pawn but
now comes looked a 7 also a possibility
for Geary was a rook captures on d6 but
it's a really long complicated line and
Geary saw that rook to e7 was enough so
he was probably reluctant to calculate
this line rook captures rook captures
and then Ruby d1 and after Luke
characters Queen captures King King
somewhere the Queen and the bishop pair
will be enough to - in this game for
example Queen d6 and now it's very hard
to find a useful move for black for
example white can just go back up d5
followed by Bishop g6 it's a game over
you can try something like check in here
and then Queen to f6 offer a queen trade
but still Queen c5 check King to d7 and
then whatever you do oh it said Bishop
to g5 will be enough to enter this game
for white you cannot go for this trade
here if you trade Queen's then you are
only up material for a brief moment as
Bishop to f4 check here takes the rook
so not an option so although it was a
very nice line it takes a lot of
calculating to do and you know it's an
open board so why why risk it
Gary decided to go for a nice safe line
with rook to
seven and now comes Bishop to e4
attacking the Queen Queen to f7 check
now if you block with the Bishop Daniel
yet who wrote the one not something you
want to do so rook here so you cannot
capture the bishop as your queen is
under attack
Queen to c4 and here we have looked the
c8 attacking the Queen also possibility
was Queen to c2 trying to trade Queens
but then Queen d4 white just gets out of
the way so rook c8 by Mahmoud er of and
now comes Queen 284 check and now what
do you do here well it's hard hard to
decide if you go King to e6 then the
rook no longer guards the bishop Queen
after Sonny 4 will come with check so
Bishop the c6 was played the Queen is
not under attack but Bishop captures on
c6 you cannot capture with the pawn the
pawn is pinned rook captures and c6 and
here we have looked to c1 and it was in
fact in this position unmoved 31 that
Sharma media resigned the game as well
as it usually is there is nothing to do
here so what's the idea behind rook to
c1
well the threat is rook captures on c6
and there is no way to prevent this
whatever you try like we said the b7
pawn is pinned you will not be able to
recapture so you may try something like
Bishop to c7 now the pond will be able
to recapture but it doesn't help just
the rook captures and after pawn
captures you can go Bishop f4 now put
some pressure here there is no way to
defend this well no good way you can try
King d8 and oh okay the rook guards the
bishop but then Queen captures on c6 the
threat is we wrote just rook to e8 and
if black wants to prevent this let's say
Queen to be it you will get Queen d5
check and after King to c8 Queen to GA
check and now there's no more there
there is no more defense whatever you
try you can't block with the bishop
because then Bishop just captures Queen
if you block with well if you just what
else is there if you go something like
in d7 then Queen captures Queen and you
cannot recapture because the bishop is
now pinned here so it's just a huge mess
of a position that really favors Gary
so after up to c1 mommy job decided
there was no point in continuing this
game and really a beautiful beautiful
miniature by Gary
and we have to ask ourselves where what
happened to black here I don't know it
seems like really here in this position
his spidey sense just wasn't working
here after Bishop to g2 if if your
opponent plays Bishop the g2 okay he
advanced the pawns in front of his king
but do you really want a Castle
queenside here
it seems that mom Europe decided that
there was no danger here
but in pretty much every game in this
tournament mom but y'all lost he just
you know looked at a position and he
assessed it as safe for for him when in
fact it wasn't it was a very dangerous
position to be in and a lot of you have
been asking that what's going on with
mommy tiara of last year he was like
twenty-eight hundred and twenty
something you know number three in the
world and this year he dropped like the
twenty seven fifty but I don't know what
what's causing this but I do know that
he's expanding his family he got a son a
little role in mahmud Europe and you
know yeah you know expanding the family
will do that some of your other you know
hobbies or jobs will have to be on hold
and it's III can only imagine but you
know probably getting a little little
boy a son into the family I will take
some toll on your chess playing skills
but I don't think this is something
permanent I think he will you know get
back to it and that it's not gonna be a
real issue for him so that's that's what
I think but you know could be could be
anything else I mean what do I know what
you ask so I tried I try to answer but
yeah now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said we're gonna show
the standings and we do have a nice
photo of two of them analyzing after the
game there you have it you know just a
nice little friendly chat after after
the game so let's just enjoy that for a
second and also let's check out the
standings after round eight so here it
is Magnus Carlsen still in first place
six points the sole lead followed by
Wesley so only one with any real chance
of catching up to him but okay I mean
those would four and a half it can still
happen it's you know it's not impossible
but what's this one second five and half
done with four and a half
Fabiano kawana young opponent former
leader up until round six and his loss
to Magnus
eleven RN and also four and a half done
with four ding Liron and then our people
with three and a half maxime beaugeois a
graph on his Girish won a tournament and
circuit kurakin and in last place with
two and a half points shot in madera and
he Cora Nakamura who can't seem to catch
a break this tournament so I don't know
what's your opinion as to why this game
went south for for my MIDI are off was
it really just a I don't know seems to
me like really just a case of his spidey
sense malfunctioning but I don't know
that that's what I think but yeah I
would like to thank Johan stead when
there Michael Burns Marshall Mariano
Joel Goodman and Matthew home for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see
soon are continuing the coverage of this
very nice event
checking governor of suggestions as
usual and well after this event were
going back to the Capablanca saga and
the match with emmanuel Lasker thank you
I will see you soon and have an
excellent dress today